People with disabilities are somehow
always different.
Wherever we are, we are changing
something in the world.
I'm at the moment where I'm trying
to confront viewers with how I live
with a disability and a non-normative body.
Society tells you what to do.
How you should move,
how you should pick a glass of water.
And if something goes away
from the norm, it's very weird.
People don't know how to react to that.
Disabled bodies in public spaces
is making a political statement,
whether they're doing anything
or not.
I always have insisted on the need
for disabled artists
or artists with learning difficulties
to take charge of those positions
like directing, teaching,
curating, programming,
producing, initiating,
and in that sense
it's happening a lot.
Each disabled artist has
a different set of needs
but I believe that the goal of art
is to create change.
For me creating, moving, dancing
is a sense of freedom
and independence
but also a form of opposition and resistance,
a form of shouting and anger.